- [Narrator] Alibaba's
e-commerce platforms,
Tencent's video games,
DiDi's ride hailing service,
these are some of China's
biggest names in tech,
and for the past several years,
foreign investors have been pouring money
into their stocks.
But this summer, those
shares listed in New York
and Hong Kong saw sharp selloffs
and it had little to do with
their business performance.
China has taken a series of actions
against big tech, and those moves,
from clamping down on
alleged monopolistic behavior
to tightening rules on data security
have sent shock waves through
international markets.
- There has been a sense
amongst Chinese officials
that some of these companies
have become a bit too powerful.
- [Narrator] In July alone,
food delivery app Meituan,
Tencent, Alibaba and short
video app Kuaishou lost
about 20% of their combined market value.
A top Chinese securities regulator
privately reassured
foreign financial firms
that the government would
consider the market impact
of its policy decisions.
But investors wonder what the future holds
of China's tech companies,
and more broadly,
for listings of Chinese companies
in the US and other countries.
- The scope and severity
of the moves recently
has taken people aback.
Many foreign investors
are kind of asking okay,
we thought we knew all the risks here
but are things actually
worse than we imagined?
(dramatic music)
- [Narrator] China has stepped up efforts
to rein in big tech.
And fast-growing firms like Tencent
and ride hailing app DiDi,
which have become central
to everyday life in China
have been subject to the clamp down.
- [Quentin] In many ways,
DiDi is the Uber of China.
- [Narrator] Earlier this year,
DiDi went public on the
New York Stock Exchange
in a multi-billion dollar IPO
that was completed in just a few days.
- It emerged that perhaps
they hadn't got the full sign off
from the Chinese authorities
or at least the Chinese authorities
had suggested to them they
might wanna hold off partly
for kind of data security reasons.
But DiDi pressed ahead.
- [Narrator] China's regulars
launched a cybersecurity probe
and suspended DiDi's apps
and said the company, which
collects a range of user data,
hadn't complied with China's
data protection rules.
Shortly after, its stock plummeted.
- [Quentin] It kind of left
investors with the sense
that DiDi had been punished
for having the temerity
to go public when it should perhaps
have been more heedful
of what Chinese regulators were saying.
- [Narrator] DiDi said it
would comply with requirements
made by relevant authorities.
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] Last year,
after billionaire Jack Ma
publicly called for regulatory changes,
Chinese authorities
targeted Ant and Alibaba,
two firms he's closely associated with.
Regulators shut down
Ant's blockbuster IPO,
which was expected to be the
world's largest public listing,
and launched an antitrust
probe into Alibaba.
Now after all these events,
markets are jittery.
In August when a state-owned
Chinese newspaper
criticized online gaming
as opium for the mind,
the stock of gaming giant
Tencent saw a massive selloff.
Tencent, also the owner of social media
and messaging platform WeChat,
has recently come under pressure
to address what authorities
are calling anti-competitive practices
and security issues.
Tencent said it would introduce new rules,
including stricter
curbs on younger gamers.
Some investors wonder
if Chinese authorities
might also target the
mechanism foreign buyers use
to invest in Chinese
stocks listed offshore.
If you're investing in certain
US-listed Chinese companies,
like Alibaba, you're not
exactly buying shares directly
in the business.
You're buying into an offshore vehicle
that has a series of legal arrangements
with the operations inside China.
This setup uses what is known as a VIE,
or a variable interest entity.
- There are literally
trillions of dollars worth
in market cap of Chinese
companies listed abroad.
And most of that is done
through these VIE structures.
Over time, some people have questioned it
because it operates in
this kind of gray area
where the Chinese authorities
might one day kind
of decide that they
don't like this loophole.
- [Narrator] Until recently,
Chinese companies going public
in the US were a bright spot
in the otherwise tumultuous
US-China relationship.
And some Chinese tech stocks
have produced big gains
for foreign investors
in the last few years.
But now everyone's watching to see
what steps Chinese
regulators will take next.
(speaking in foreign language)
- There is a sense maybe
that the Chinese regulators
were kind of blindsided
by how severe the foreign reaction was.
They don't wanna completely close the door
on the outside world,
and they don't want to
completely terrify markets.
But they also are pretty resolute
about what they feel they need to do,
and they feel like this is all good
for the long-term development
of the Chinese economy.
It seems like the campaign isn't over.